[Music]
for five hours flames ripped through
this four-story commercial building in
new delhi
inside dozens of people burned to death
desperate some of the survivors jumped
through windows
people including women were breaking
glass and jumping out all the air
conditioning units in the building were
on fire about 15 of them authorities had
cut the water and the power supply
outside this hospital families wait for
updates
hoping their relatives are still alive
firefighters rescued about 70 people but
their whereabouts are unclear
i've gone to several hospitals looking
for my wife the trauma hospital the
memorial hospital and now here it's my
third attempt
rescue units look through what's left
searching for more victims and clues
the flames started on the first floor
which mostly has offices delhi's fire
services say the building had no
clearance no fire extinguishers or
proper safety equipment
there was only one exit
and with the flames burning no one could
escape
fires are common in india building laws
and safety norms are often ignored by
both builders and residents
an investigation is underway
for now that's of little comfort for
families facing this loss
katie lopez al jazeera